grow as meat
okay
no no that's not what you said you said
something else what did i say
hey guys it's katie and i'm here with my
friend jasmine and today she's going to
be teaching me one of her favorite
recipes that she ate growing up
so
i will give you a few lifelines one
google it
two
phone a friend being my brother
and number three phone my mother oh
that'll be fun katy do you know any
mandarin no any other languages i took
german and like i've done this with um
anaket in india and he spoke hindi but
like
i really don't know okay do you want to
learn some basics yes please i
desperately please okay should i count
to five yes five okay six a child one
one
[Music]
there's two people on this side of the
seesaw that's why it's going
down because it's heavier sure whatever
helps you
eat
sun
sen yes okay
oh
okay so it's like a check mark yeah yes
yes
do i sound like a child to you when i do
it you sound american
like an american baby i will go over the
ingredients one time yes you're gonna do
this we're going through them one time
and then
one time that's on your own you heard
the lifelines you use them when you need
them okay i'm ready okay giannio roll
chow chow chow niro
[Music]
garlic for this one furikake
there's actually not a word for it i
don't think but i grew up calling it
sasa so rice seasoning is salsa yeah
which kind of means like sprinkle
sprinkle yo
yo
yo
no no wait yo yo is oil
green onions
i'm just helping myself remember yeah
can you walk me these are drumsticks and
i don't know what they're just making
they make it though
my oh sesame oil me me is rice
me love me me love me too
hey hooch out pepper yes
oh it's spicy hey huchao hey watch out
hey we're so spicy
i'm trying to help myself remember all
right you ready
i forgot everything before
me
okay i heard me yeah
is that like
yes do it
you know what that's yes it sounds like
duh
no time
oh but how much
wait is that okay e er e1 er two
okay so a water
to wash [ __ ] she
i'm going to rinse this out i'm going to
pour this out and do this a few more
times just to get excess starch off the
rice
rice rinsed ready to go
[Laughter]
so i'm going to put this i haven't used
a rice cooker in a long time
oh you use it all the time you use the
rice cooker all the time wow like every
day you use it every day
i think that was good oh you had to put
rice you gotta put water in this
way sen sen is for sen no is
sen is three is three
sante
[Music]
[Music]
we're going to let it go till it beeps
but like i need to put some time on it
right don't add just press start
an hour if this is an hour
next well missions i should i go wide
okay
i'm trying okay one more time one a bowl
a new bowl
roll
[Music]
all right um
yes a cup of water we need more water
no no no no oh oh cup
e
one i got one bae
one cup one cup one cup one half it's
half a cup it's half a cup of e half of
one cup e
b one and a half cup
okay so a cup and a half of gelatin url
i should use lifeline i feel like i've
stayed on this too long okay i'm going
to google you're going to google it i'm
using google in everyone
google so ground beef
a cup
liang tang chi dianio two
tablespoons jungyo of
changmyo which i think is soy sauce only
because
okay okay
[Music]
is that sesame oil
oh brown sugar don't have sugar because
you love boba
[Music]
two tablespoons of this into there yes
yes yes okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay wait let's do it again
my eyes are watering we all cool i'm not
crying
that's like cool
it's the gunian it's the gun
to
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god two teaspoons mayo mayo which
is sesame oil
is oil
you know that i love pepper jolly gel
joey joe oh joe
joey gel oh
[Music]
oh we're going to chill this we're going
to let it like marinade milk
oh let's get a frying pan
half
like medium heat
medium heat i think i'm just reading
your body language that's all i'm doing
oil
turn up the heat okay i'm turning up the
heat
when should i turn it take it off the
heat
yeah okay
me rice rice this is
yes the rice is done let me tell you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
sesame oil half a tablespoon
no that's not right
half a teaspoon teaspoon as well
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay a quarter cup tattoo a quarter
tablespoon
a portable tick
what am i having
a quarter teaspoon that okay a quarter
teaspoon yen
salt
gotta have that salt
mixing mix
this is gonna be so good
nero
jamunda
that's not a word you said jumanji
[Laughter]
i think i need a lifeline so we're
calling your i'm gonna call your mom
hello
hi mom yes so katie needs help hi
oh hi kitty hi ma i'm going to say it in
mandarin and then you're just going to
tell katie what the translation is
okay
and in ground beef add in ground beef
i should have thought of that
thank you okay bye
[Music]
mix it thank you
sorry
take a quarter cup of the mixture
i have to use less another one i have
one left okay hey alvin okay hi funzai
[Music]
putting it on my hand
did you make a ball
because i said ball earlier and you're
if you were like whoa
make a bun
one continue making balls
doll male fat just use the rest
okay so i'm just gonna keep making balls
i finished
i got my balls
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right we are done let me get mine
they look the same what different same
same but different yours look better no
yours are so beautiful my meat chunks
are thick they are but that means some
juicy bites yes what is this called
these are korean rice balls they are
called
my korean's not as good as my mandarin
so i couldn't have done this in korean
not yet not yet still working on it
you can use that rice ball they're right
but they look delicious my mom would
make these for school lunches or these
would be like hiking foods oh cool um
they're really easy to put in a it's
like a ziploc bag and then you can like
push them up in your ziploc bag and just
like take five i want to try them yeah
let's do it okay yes do you want to try
mine first yes please
cheers
oh good
they're a little sweet i guess that's
brown sugar brown sugar in the beef the
meat pretty much a korean barbecue
marinade it's so good we did great i did
a good job
with your house i'm just gonna mm-hmm
it's kind of deceiving right the size
it's like a lot let's try yours i'm
gonna see
if i got anything wrong with
measurements-wise cheers cheers
it tastes nice i like that your beef is
smaller
because it's more dispersed through your
out your bite better balanced and you
don't even have to add the ground beef
you can add some vegetables you can put
a little like avocado mash in the middle
this is genius this is a good snack it's
like a sandwich you can make a million
different sandwiches you can make a
million different kinds of rice balls
all up to your own preferred
i love it i'm going to start doing this
i feel like i have seaweed in my teeth
do i
it's actually right in the middle
do i
everywhere
i'm just kidding
jasmine thank you so much for teaching
me this delicious recipe for teaching me
mandarin i i mean i'm not fluent but i
feel like i learned a lot today you
agree how do i say how do we say goodbye
they're still wrestling
honestly we just say bye-bye
[Music]
you